he's doing terrific Roberts good yeah
he's working out and eating good and so
he's on a good path right now he's back
[Music]
Rob Kardashian hit up Instagram on
Sunday to share a bunch of pics from his
sister Khloe Kardashian's 36th birthday
bash and guys he looks great
we love having him around doing good
yeah he's doing really good the proud
papa looked happy and healthy posing it
up with his siblings Khloe and Kourtney
as well as Kendall and Kylie Jenner
rocking a black sweatshirt black pants
and sneakers and that's Rob next to his
sister's exes Scott Disick and Tristan
Thompson his caption whoo back baby
of course rob has been noticeably absent
from the spotlight in recent years and
he rarely ever shares pictures of
himself on Instagram the last time we
caught a glimpse of the 33 year old on
his social media was in November when he
shared this Halloween pic with his mama
Kris Jenner in March a source told ET
that the former reality star was doing
really well quote Rob continues to work
on staying healthy for himself and his
daughter dream the source added that he
and his family have a great relationship
and he loves having his nieces and
nephews around now that most of the
family has young kids growing up
together the family is tighter than ever
Rob's doing great he really is last year
Scott and Khloe told ET that Rob was
crushing it in the gym with the help of
his big sis
Kim you know he's been working out a
couple you know so Kim he goes to Kim's
he's worked out for like the past five
days or so and he's kicking ass and I
just want Rob to do what's best for him
and what makes him happy and if that
makes him happy then we will all support
him as for Kim she told et in November
that she and her brother really
connected the past year or two he's
doing great you know he definitely is
more low-key than all of us and we love
that and respect that
[Music]